welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 10 and
we're gonna learn how billionaires
overcome rejection enjoy
[Music]
even today we still have a lot of people
reject us
i think when i uh
in the graduate from universities and
before i
you know for three years i tried to fill
in the universities
so i applied jobs for 30 times
got rejected i went for a police they
said no you're not good
i went to even the uh kfc when kfc came
to china come to my city
24 people went for the job
23 people accepted i was the only one
guy
and we went for police five people four
of them accepted i was the only guy that
i re
receiving so to me being turned down
rejected oh by the way i told you that i
would i applied for harvard
for 10 times rejected i know i'd be
rejected
sorry now 10 times you wrote them and
said
i'd like to come to harvard yeah and
then i told myself somebody i should go
teach their baby
our first ipo years year 2007 when
alibaba
appealed in hong kong year 2007
we had a lot of millionaires in the
company
and i asked my friend my colleagues are
like we have like a 300 people
become millionaires and i ask them hey
now tell me
you become millionaires because you are
smarter than the others
people say no no no no no we even cannot
find the jobs
because you're hard working yes we were
have we we find more people hard working
than us but they do not succeed one of
why they're not smart
all the smart people at that time they
went to microsoft and ibm
and head hunting companies came to
headhunt all the best guy from us
and we are the people nobody comes ahead
of us
we have no place to go we believe in
ourself
we believe our dream we work together
so i say we are the people because
nobody wants us
i am the person over 30 companies don't
want to make
right so we are the people get used to
be
rejected we are the people get used to
be
say no from the other people why people
should help you
people help you that is unusual
people do not help you that is very
common
you should work to earn to be helped
people like us we are getting used to be
criticized
we are getting used to be said no
people say no to you when people say yes
to you
we really appreciate because it's not
you know why people should say yes to
you you have to prove
so as the entrepreneur you have to get
used to be
challenged have to get used to be said
no by the other people by the found by
the investors
by your customers by the people but this
this is the
opportunity when everybody believe it
you have no chance
when only a few people believe it you
believe it you prove it that's your
chance
in the beginning nobody wanted a tesla i
can tell you that
uh the the the
when we made the original sort of roads
to sports car
uh people were like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline car works fine
i'm like no electric car cars better
should try it um
and it was you know hard to get people
to
do a test drive first one nobody knew
who we were
and then we heard this company and like
yeah we're named after nikola tesla you
know that guy nope
um um so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said
there was no one telling us that they
wanted an electric car so it was not it
was not out of like
you know it's like lots of people coming
up to me saying hey i really want an
electric car
i heard that zero times um
somebody like it's like man we're gonna
make an electric car and show that these
things can be good
um and then people want them um
you know it's like i think it's like
henry ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say
a faster horse so if you did like a big
survey and said well hey
public before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster
and eat less food and uh
you know be stronger and live longer and
that kind of thing
um there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's that sounds crazy but
when you actually make an automobile and
give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
yeah so carry more
more weight than a horse and go further
and that kind of thing so
yeah it's like when when it's a
radically
new product people don't know that they
want it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey i think
this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey
will you ever buy a tv now it was like
96 percent of respondents said no
hmm some crazy number like basically
everyone's like would you buy a tv
and maybe they put a price in there or
something i don't know but it was
famously almost everyone said they would
not buy tv
but they didn't know what they're
talking about we really tried hard to
convince a lot of companies honestly i
was in so many panels
but um they're generally worth yeah
generally
the settlement that was expressed that
you mentioned earlier that was pretty
much universal
um especially uh if back in say 2008
or 2007 like when we first unveiled the
roads from 2007
um yeah i mean it was just basically
they just said well you're basically a
bunch of fools well
i mean generally they say like well who
starting a car company is crazy you're
going to lose all your money
i was like i think i probably will lose
all my money i agree
it wasn't like i thought it would be
successful i thought we had maybe a 10
chance of success
so then people would say you're it's
going to fail and you're going to lose
lose everything i was like yeah probably
true yeah
what else is new if you come up with an
idea where you say i can make dollar
bills for 50 cents
would you go out and raise money or
would you just go out and sell it
you just go out and do it you know and
and that's what you have to do and look
we all go through that fear factor of do
i quit my job
do i can i do this um can i
can i do this and what happens next
the one thing i know with 100 certainty
and what i would tell
myself is if i can sell
and become a better and better
salesperson and be great at selling
i'm always going to be successful
whether i'm working for myself
or if the company that i started just
didn't work
i'll give you an example
out of indiana before i went down to
dallas
i needed to start something and um i
decided that
everybody drank milk and i found this
product powdered milk
that was cheaper and everybody needed to
save money
and i was going to go out there and sell
it
because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good
and so what i've but i went out there to
try to sell it
failed miserably but i learned
how to make the sales effort even when
things weren't going right
i learned that the rejection was
every no got me closer to a yes that not
every product was perfect
but i could take those same skills even
in failure
and translate them so that what i
learned selling garbage bags door to
door what i learned from selling
powdered milk that was awful what i
learned from
selling local area networks at micro
solutions
all those things accumulated and i i got
better at selling so i always knew
you know people always say to me if you
lost everything what would you do
i can sell i can sell and it's not about
selling ice to eskimos it's not about
you know convincing people to do this
selling is always about
helping selling is always about
understanding
the person you're talking to and what
their needs are and
if someone can help me make my life
easier
yeah people you know now with employees
people always say like
what's the definition of a great
employee
someone who can reduce the stress of
those around them and it's the same
thing what's the definition of a great
salesperson
someone who can reduce the stress of
their sales people and
if in looking at your company and
looking at your
your life and looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize
that whether it works or doesn't work
you're putting yourself in a position
where you're helping somebody
not convincing somebody but and you're
reducing their stress
you're gonna you're gonna be okay it's
gonna work out and
you know that's the confidence i i've
built in myself that wasn't necessarily
always there
um but i learned that if i try to help
if i reduce people's stress good things
can happen we all are
entrepreneurs or wonder if we're
entrepreneurs at heart you know we all
have that
idea inside of us we've all been through
it oh i got this idea it's a great idea
you know when you get all excited you
get that feeling in your stomach right
and then you go to google and you go ah
there's nobody else doing this
ah then you call your friends you go
what do you think what do you think oh
that is really cool i'd buy
one you know and then most people stop
you know what's for dinner but
some people they found their way to turn
those into companies and they found
their way onto shark tank
and we got to see examples of people
from any little town
and any you know anywhere in the country
with
backgrounds that weren't from some big
ivy league school
maybe you didn't go to college at all
maybe it was their last dollar and they
started it up and
and they were desperate to get an
investment but they started it
and we showed examples of people who are
willing to take that first step
and and start that company and where it
could go and i think that really
and to this day really excites people
and gets that encourages them
and and really shows them that there can
be an upside
and on the flip side you know there can
be failure too
and so you have to be realistic about
what can happen don't stop looking for a
job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know
that there's not opportunity there
because all it takes is one
if you just if if you grind it out and
you continue to be persistent
whether it's emailing calling you know
setting up on seminars whatever it may
be however you can connect with people
applying for jobs to wherever however do
it you know every note gets you closer
to a yes and all it takes is that one
opportunity
to propel you to where you look to be
and you know
and i guess adding to that again like i
said earlier
there there's so many new things going
on when you know when i came out of
college
way back when um the was the last time
that unemployment was in
double digits you know my friends you
know i remember reading the story i went
to indiana university
talking about how the unemployment rate
in northern indiana was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today
and i had to be mobile right i had to go
from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that that i could platform
and so as you look for these things you
you really
have to be more adventurous if you will
and be more mobile
and be more flexible and agile and and
that's not necessarily a bad thing you
don't have to get
the best job you don't have to get a
perfect job you just have to get
a job and now all of a sudden you're
getting paid to learn and you can
platform that just like an mba free
agent right
they might spend one year or two year at
one two years at one team
build their skill set to get better and
go to a better situation
looking and finding a job looking and
finding an internship
looking at building your skills that to
prepare yourself for what comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
how do you deal with failure
and what's your advice to young
entrepreneurs like me in this case
especially with regards to failure and
how to approach it yeah well
if if you fail you really do dust
yourself off and
you know get right back in i mean you're
going to fail at some things
uh uh you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out uh
you know fairly significant number of
people get divorced i mean
you know that's a very big decision to
have turn out badly but uh
i think if you study almost everybody
and
read read kay's book you know personal
history and you'll
everybody fails at some things i mean
you know particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and just
knowing about whatever it may be
businesses uh but
you know it it is not fatal i mean if
you're healthy
and you live in this particular living
in this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school
uh when i was when i got out of the
university of nebraska you know
and i remember you know i went to
chicago to get interviewed this is when
you
traveled on the train and so i spent 10
hours going there and
this fellow looked at me and about 10
minutes he said you know
forget it belle and now i've got to go
back on the train 10 hours and think
what am i going to tell my dad well tell
my dad i mean my dad always told me i
could do anything
and everything now i've just got just
gotten turned down uh
you know but it turned out that one of
the best things ever happened to me
because then i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact it probably
even affected who i married because i
took a one-year course at columbia and
said two years at harvard and she might
have found some other guy
during that time almost everything in my
life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually that's turned into a
success i mean it it
the world isn't over you know if you
have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean that there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but
but the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and
you know you've got decades ahead of you
you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know
they're doing things you don't approve
of or they're not treating you fairly
you know the world isn't over yet you
know you just go out
and find somebody else i'm very lucky to
have been in
silicon valley and silicon valley is
very lucky to have
been able to benefit from you know the
semiconductor
boom and then software and now internet
and mobile
um i mean i think it's
there's a huge amount of luck there
but the luck also comes from taking
many shots you know so many
failures you know if i told you all the
dumb things that i did
um you know we'd have to have much
longer session uh
and and the successes you know they
often are
chance i mean i mentioned the google
brain work that they were just off in
the corners like okay fine just
you know do your thing uh our um
you know verily which is uh our
subsidiary that does a wide range of
healthcare innovation now
i really started with this glucose
sensing contact lens project
um and that was another one where i said
uh this fellow babak and brian otis who
were working on it
uh you know and they wanted to put a
computer in a contact lens and i was
like you know what that sounds crazy but
you know you go do your crazy thing you
know you can only have a couple people
work on it i'm not going to give you a
lot of resources
uh but uh you know sure if you put a
computer in contact lens good for you
and yet here they are uh you know a few
years later and they're you know running
uh you know they're doing serious
studies now they have a big partnership
with
artists and alcon uh and they are
um you know hopefully going to bring
those to market
alongside with a bunch of other projects
that that has spawned
and i didn't know anything about that
and i never would have predicted or
guessed
that i think we're just lucky to have
the environment that tolerates
you know making lots of risky bets and
tolerating the failures that inevitably
result
my approach to criticism and what i
teach and preach
inside amazon is when you're criticized
first look in a mirror and decide
are your critics right if they're right
change there are two kinds of critics
there are well-meaning critics um who
you know they they're worried it's not
going to work
but they do want it to work and so it
could be i could give you example
customer reviews would be one of those
um when we first did customer reviews 20
years ago
publishers or some book publishers were
not happy about it because some of them
were negative
and so it was very controversial
practice at that time but we thought it
was right and so we stuck to our guns
and
and and and had a deep kill on that and
didn't didn't change
um but uh there's a second kind
of critic which is the self-interested
critic and they come in all shapes and
sizes
you know they're um so they can be any
kind of institution
competitors um of course and so
when you are doing something a new way
and if customers embrace the new way
what's going to happen is incumbents who
are practicing the older way
are not going to like you and they're
going to be self-interested critics and
so you do need as you're looking
yourself
in the mirror to try and tease those two
things apart
the best advice i could give is number
one
be prepared for a lot of rejection
if you're ready for rejection of people
say no i don't want it no it's not going
to work no this
is crazy whatever if you're prepared for
it it's not going to let you down
learn from your failures i had a lot of
failures along the way
even with my patronum paul mitchell but
we learn from those things and we get a
lot better
i would call myself a girl who really
likes to challenge herself to do things
that scare her
to auditioning at disney world i ended
up at disney world because i failed the
lsat
and i felt very sad that
i most likely wasn't going to be heading
off to law school i am a terrible test
taker
so i did what my parents said of course
would be the most natural thing to do
and i got in my car and drove to disney
world and tried out to be goofy
and just to add you know
insult to injury i'm too short to be
goofy so i just failed the lsat i went
through all the auditions to become a
character and you have to be five eight
to be goofy and i'm five six so i'm the
height of a chipmunk
oh really yes so they wanted to make me
a chipmunk
then she found herself selling fax
machines by day and pursuing her spanx
stream by night
my father growing up used to encourage
my brother and me to fail
and that he would say at the dinner
table what have you guys failed at this
week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember saying dad i tried
out for this and i was
horrible and he'd high five me and say
way to go and what he was doing was
reframing my definition of failure i
didn't realize it at the time but
for my brother myself failure ended up
becoming not trying
versus the outcome handling kind of
criticism and people saying don't do
that or you can't do that because
you know on any kind of success journey
you do get a lot of that what how did
you kind of
handle that yeah you know in the
beginning you're not ready for
i was not ready for the amount of
um criticism you know first you're going
to be ignored
in the beginning you're just going to be
ignored nobody's going to even pay
attention to you you could be jesus
you could walk on water and they're
going to ignore you nobody'll even see
hey did you see that did you take a
selfie
did you get it on instagram if you
didn't it didn't happen so it doesn't
matter like you could literally save the
world and if nobody saw it
they're going to ignore you in the
beginning then they're going to reject
you
third thing they're going to do is
they're going to criticize you make fun
of you
but if you stay with it they're gonna
adopt it okay i mean brilliant people
are adopted at the end
if they just stay with the hate along
the way is part of the game
for you to get past being ignored and
then rejected you will be hated on
and once you start accumulating enough
success
uh we we were uh i told my team over
here we got 155 employees i'm like guys
look
you have to be ready it's coming the
criticism
the stuff online don't even look at it
it's all garbage
and if it affects you negatively
it's not about what they're saying it's
about what it does to you personally
i just know it's part of the game now in
the beginning i wasn't ready for it now
i understand oh
my success is dependent upon the hate
and the criticism and the rejection
you got to have it it's part of the it's
part of the recipe of success
unfortunately
because people that quit are going to
hate you for not quitting
they're actually not talking about you
they're talking about themselves
and they're like he's wrong for having a
damn plane
because they quit on their play
everybody can have a plane
the crazy is everybody can have
everything they want because there's
enough to go around for everybody
so uh for every guy that doesn't have
what he wants there's somebody on this
planet that has the oceanfront house
that goes on as many trips as they want
some guy that's got the 200-foot yacht
some guy that funded a hospital
somewhere and put his name on it
and and you know it's just crazy
that the hate always comes from the same
place
a quitter haters actually own haters
they're quitters
nobody's got more haters than that but
it stops a lot of people and it doesn't
stop you
yeah because because because i i you
know it's a different
for me like
i understand that
if you get if you're gonna get success
you're gonna get the haters that's the
price
or one of the costs that's one of the
prices okay so because
it goes back to what i said earlier all
haters
first of all we should not admire haters
the way we do
we even call them haters they're not
haters they're quitters
they're quitters all haters are quitters
like this should be this should be the
title of your your thing is a quiz
all haters all haters including
me anytime i hate on something okay
i am a i quit on that thing like i hate
drugs
i quit drugs i hate drugs i hate people
that use drugs i don't trust people that
use drugs
like no drug is safe for me and and i
know i believe
that no drug is safe for other people
now some people can be like no no i'm
using cannabis
recreational it's cool man i use
psychedelics and i do this good dude i
hate drugs i want to make it clear i
hate drugs and i i hate drugs for you
and i hate trucks for him i hate drugs
for everybody so i can be wrong
but right now i'm gonna hate drugs why
because i quit drugs
now if you're hating on grant cardone
and i hadn't done anything to you
i'm over here minding my own business or
building my own business
you know minding micromanaging my own
business so it grows
so so if i'm doing that okay and you're
hating on me why are you hating on me
now he uses social media too much these
are every example i go over it's because
you don't use it enough
he works too much because you don't use
you you don't work enough
uh he doesn't spend enough time with his
kids you don't even have kids
like i got people hating on me because i
got my kids
on my plane oh you're gonna ruin your
kids if i'm gonna ruin my kids i'm gonna
ruin them private
you know so so um what are you quitting
on like
so it's very very important for me like
when i hate on somebody i need to
understand
did i quit on something or am i
legitimately hating on this person
for a reason because i'm trying to make
a i'm trying to make a statement
publicly
and there are there are people i
publicly
hate on and why do you do that because i
want to make it clear
that they should not be doing business
with this person they should not be
admiring this person they should not
like as an opinion leader i think i have
some responsibility to tell people do
you you don't want to follow that if
you're going to follow him don't follow
me
yeah you can't follow both of us
and think that you're going to get any
place which is a huge problem today with
social media
you got to get some haters you need
haters
no school is going to teach you how to
get a hater
okay high school elementary school
colleges what do they teach you want to
be the most popular person no you want
haters
okay the companies that are hated are
the companies that are exploding
the people that are hated are the people
that explode
if i don't hate you if nobody hates you
nobody knows you
so the reason i'll tweet for instance
when we started we had this
uh that newsletter that i sent out okay
we sent it out every week
we were hitting people once a month and
we started getting complaints
you send stuff out too much my office
came to me
we went to twice a month they came to me
we have
more people pulling off of the
newsletter
good double up again
why i want haters
okay so we started sending out one every
week and then i started twitter account
i actually had people write grant
cardone social media people
grant cardone is an example of what not
to do with social media i said freaking
just multiply just
increase it okay we were doing like four
tweets a day good due to an hour
why because i want my competition hating
my guts i want them talking about me i
mean i don't really want hate people to
hate me you understand what i'm saying
about
i want them so so energized that they
actually start pushing me
[Music]
they start promoting me let me tell you
number one number one
they're coming for you they're coming
for you they've been coming at me my
whole life my entire life i've always
been a dreamer i've always had
big ideas always thought even as a
little kid i was gonna do big things
i mean there was no basis no rationale
to my dreams
you know i've always had a big mouth
always had an opinion
so if you're like that haters are coming
you know what i'm talking about okay
they can be close to you they can be far
away they can be in the neighborhood
they can be in the school they could be
at the bank they can be at work
you could work for them or they can work
for you but they are coming
okay if you dream big if you talk big
when you start making any money you
start making any moves
write an article on linkedin okay have
an opinion about anything about anything
make a move and the haters will come out
now
what i want to do is i want to tell you
i handle them okay i've done a great job
over my life of figuring out how to
handle these people
and making sure they don't stop me from
making the moves
i want to make for my family for myself
and to make my dreams a reality
so number one you need to understand
that the haters
okay dude they're not even talking to
you okay
i see so many of you responding to them
taking the time to talk to them
trying to trying to make sense of them i
remember a man told me a man told me
once he's like grant how do you make
sense of insanity i said uh
i don't know how do you do that he's
like you don't when you're talking to
somebody's insane pal
ladies gentlemen when you're talking to
somebody that's crazy
by the way the hater is crazy okay
when you're talking to somebody that's
crazy insane
hating on you you don't never
you never try to make sense of it don't
try to talk to them don't try to talk
them out of it okay
number one number two understand you got
to understand that the hater
is not talking to you i know everybody
thinks they all in part and you're like
oh i'm so important i'm so important
they must be talking to me they talking
to me about me
they're not talking to you okay the
suffer is not only the
that's selfish the hater is not only
okay insane
the hater is extremely extremely
self-centered
they're not thinking about you okay you
made them think about themselves you
wrote an article or you did a video
or you were on stage or you spoke or you
wrote a book
or you had a score you're telling
somebody about your score they're hating
on you because they're thinking about
themselves
you now have reminded them your success
your action
your score has reminded them
of what they don't do
get it so why would you respond to
somebody that's number one insane and
number two
they're so self-centered they don't they
they're not talking about you they're
talking about themselves to themselves
that's all they think of is themselves
and by the way number three they're
stupid they're so stupid
they end up promoting the very person
they're envious of do you understand
when a
when somebody hates on a movie a book
release
a speaking engagement somebody's score
all they're doing is promoting that
person
nobody promotes me better than my haters
nobody i would never
ever get rid of my haters they are the
best free promotion
i can get anywhere in the world the
people that i want to know me aren't
hating on me
the people i want to do business with
they there's no hate
uh you know i don't know why what i stir
up in these people
do you think i think part of it is is my
work ethic though i think part of it is
people are trying to figure out
how does that guy show up every single
day what what is running him
what is driving him to produce guys that
are on
a similar level and have the same
capability and and possibilities
i think some of those guys are like
why am i not revved up like he is how
can you stop
zip zeros how could you stop something
and create something at the same time
impossible
that's the beauty of the hater baby
haters create nothing you do with the
hater okay so you let them stay on your
streams you say these horrible things
you block
what do you do what do you do right i
block them no first thing you do is try
to make sense of them
yeah that's a mistake never make sense
of insanity
how do you make sense of insanity you
don't man you don't
you simply don't try to make sense of it
okay number two
don't ever try to stop the haters you'll
notice my facebook my twitter
my youtube i rarely stop anybody from
hate
but do you block them there'll be
there'll be a couple of times i block
okay say anything
sexual say anything about religions i'm
pr i'm i'm a block yeah i just i
have no tolerance the first amendment
right in this country is freedom of
religion
and speech yes and speech so hey all
you think i suck you think i'm terrible
you think my material is no good you
think it's not gonna work you think i'm
whatever a con artist bro bring it on
post that on my page
i will not take you down okay you start
talking about kids or sex
it's just not appropriate for my
audience you talk about me
not being legit businessman you start
asking you start saying i'm worth 20
million when that ain't true i ain't
gonna block you i'm gonna let everybody
else tell you what i'm worth
i don't need to tell you look it up okay
cause you ain't talking about my net
worth you're talking about the fact that
you ain't got any net worth
let me tell you something else that guy
don't have he ain't got any self-worth
haters don't even hate other people man
they hate themselves if you're having to
explain yourself
they're either not your friend
not a supporter they're not on your team
don't know who the boss is
or they're straight up enemies what i'm
telling you is you got to quit trying to
explain yourself to people
okay you shouldn't have to explain
yourself the people that love you
support you
are behind you with you i'm not talking
about the people who sleep with you the
people you're born with
mommies daddies uncles aunts even wifeys
and husb
just because you live with them don't
believe believe me
mean they believe believe in you okay
they might not be on the page you know
what i'm saying so look check it out
if you got to explain it to them they're
not your friends they're not your
supporters
they're not behind you and if you do
have to explain it and they're your
enemies they're not gonna believe you
anyway
so quit explaining yourself
right you gotta know you gotta know
what's true for you
you gotta know what's working you gotta
know what you're gonna do
if you're gonna lead your team if you're
gonna be the boss the boss makes
decisions the boss makes
writes checks the boss is willing to
pull the trigger and the boss by the way
will be the first person to change his
course when it's not working
so look i don't explain myself to
anybody okay when i do
it's always when i make the mistake it's
always to somebody that doesn't
understand what i'm doing anyway
doesn't have any competency in the space
and are
is a straight-up hating enemy
trying to do me wrong and those people
you can explain total truth to them they
still won't believe it
because they can't make sense of it the
incompetent can't make sense of the
truth
and your enemies well
come on keep it real they just refuse to
believe anything
so look quit explaining yourself right
listen to it man it's deep it's
deep quit explaining yourself doesn't
mean you're responsible doesn't mean you
don't have an open mind doesn't mean you
were not willing to be wrong
doesn't mean you're not willing to
change course quit explaining yourself
because the people that love you support
you and behind you
they'll be like dude let's do it that
way let's roll let's roll let's roll
and then you as the boss is a legit boss
will change course if it's not working
they crucified jesus
like what are you worried about somebody
somebody disliked you he gave you a bad
comment on youtube
which which does the guy doesn't even
have an avatar like he doesn't even have
his picture on there is it just
he's x four one two three seven
uh porn all the time yeah that's his
hands
32 000 on on linkedin so that's a huge
amount well yeah but people on linkedin
don't hate they don't hate they just
don't comment you get to youtube and
they're like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you're
an idiot you know linkedin's for losers
porn all night long no avatar
yeah you know yeah get a picture of a
cartoon character
yeah because they always do they're just
cowards and quitters yeah yeah
so so you got but you got to get them
because they generate a lot of activity
so how do i get more haters
you you need to have a bigger opinion
about stuff yeah i'd say
you need to get your opinion i'm pushing
it already but i need to put it on yeah
yeah you know you know dude
i mean i could show you some tricks for
getting haters like i know how to get
them
so do you do interviews with people that
that that you disagree with
you know what you know don't just
collaborate with like-minded people you
like yeah
you know do do some stuff with people
you're like dude that's just stupid yeah
yeah
you know like try that one time just
give me that that's a stupid grant
that's just super great you didn't do it
good enough
you can't roll your eyes when you do it
you got to lean into it the whole thing
you know so and you and do you talk do
but look i'm not trying to go get haters
just so you know i don't have a
a like we don't have some kind of
strategy to go acquire haters
why are the successful people why don't
you
ever hear about them why don't they ever
talk about what they're doing where
they're going their trips where they
live
like you know
[Music]
they hide they get successful and then
they hide and the reason why
is because they start getting people
hating on them
and hating on success and resenting them
and envious of them
and they finally say you know what i'm
just going to pull the curtains and
nobody's going to see how i live my life
how i got where i'm at
what i'm doing you know how i'm
operating how much money
i give away to charity you don't end up
knowing anything except oh man that guy
he's off on a boating trip you know
i mean literally the family unit the
only time they they they share anything
is when
it's at easter thanksgiving the family i
mean it becomes a really closed
almost a closed society like a secret
thing how they became successful
so you don't get to find nobody gets to
learn anything from from these
super uber successful
guys because they start pulling the
curtains in front of them to protect
themselves and their family
and as risky as it is because i know
people are going to be like oh the guy's
arriving in his roles and he's showing
his car off and he's on his plane and
showing it off
and he's you know shooting video in his
apartment showing that off
okay well what you could think that i'm
showing it off
some people will think that and me and
my wife know that that's gonna happen
but that's not our intention okay other
people are like i'm inspired
and that's really the goal you know is
not to pull the curtains
closed and not to hide and
but to some kid maybe 10 or 12 years old
you know doesn't have a dad like i
didn't have a dad
or or he maybe his dad's gone or maybe
who knows where he is man he could be in
a foster home he could be
maybe he's maybe he's in a family where
the dad and the mom are there
but they're working their ass off so
hard they really still the kids really
still
fatherless and and uh so maybe he sees
this video on youtube and and says
wow man you know
dude who doesn't want to have nice
things come on
who doesn't want to have nice things and
by the way who would think
nice things are a bad thing like what
happened to us that we're like
we don't want nice things and we think
nice things are out of
out of reach or we think nice things
aren't necessary
or that cars too much or that's too much
you know or
you know like some people some people be
like what man 400 grand for a car why
don't you just give that money to
charity
hey why don't i do this why don't i do
both now i've got some special bonus
clips that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
rejection leads to success all you have
to do is look at the people that you
look up to
look at the people that are profiled on
my youtube channels and what you'll find
is rejection after rejection after
rejection
so rejection lead to success you know
this intellectually you already know
this
but when you get into the situation
where you have to face rejection
then your emotions take over your fears
take over and you don't do the thing
that you might get rejected for even
though you know
logically because in that moment your
emotions your fear
are greater than your logic i had a
life-changing fear of rejection
situation happened to me in paris when i
was
18 years old and i was there when i was
on the street
outside the notre dame cathedral and i
had a map in front of me and this cute
girl comes up to me and she asks for
directions
and i wanted to ask her out and i was
too afraid i was too embarrassed i was
too ashamed
i was too worried that i might get
rejected in my head
the only thing to think of was i want to
ask her out
and she might reject me she might say no
and so what did i do nothing now
if i had logically stood to the side
press
timeout you know pause the situation say
evan logically what makes sense
logically you know she might say no
and you're okay you'll move on with the
rest of your day logically she might say
yes why is why is she coming up to you
asking for directions why is she asking
for directions when
she already speaks perfect french and
she seems like a local
right logically that's what makes the
most sense
logically i should have summoned the
courage to go off and do it
but in the moment your emotions take
over your fear takes over
that idea that you might get rejected
takes over and so what did i do
nothing i let her walk away
and ever since that day i reminded
myself that
i would rather know and fail than not
know
and i use that painful moment to
whenever i am thinking about
doing something i'm afraid of rejection
for afraid of it not working out
then i have to do it that that moment is
what led me to become an entrepreneur
because a year later when i had the
chance to have my dream job and make
100k a year
travel around the world or be an
entrepreneur on 30
of a business and make 300 a month i had
that picture in my head where i was
thinking
i can't let this happen again i don't
want to live with regret i would rather
know and fail than not know
and that gave me the courage to keep
going
so i know you guys know this i know you
know it intellectually i know
every success story that you read is
motivating and it's inspiring to you and
you see all the rejections
but then when you get faced with it when
you're face to face
with that fear tend to play small
you tend to do the thing that you're not
proud of and then you tend to live with
regret
so how do you get rid of it how do you
get through that tough situation that
fear of rejection and not let your
emotions take over
i'm gonna give you a three-step strategy
that will help step number one
is create a stronger negative emotion so
people say
be fearless i don't i don't think you
can i think i think if you're living
a great life you should be constantly
doing things that you're afraid of right
if you have no
fear then it means you're doing
something that
is normal that is inside your comfort
zone you're photocopying your life over
and over and over again
so it's not be fearless it's when you
are afraid of something at least for me
create a stronger negative emotion which
is regret
so here's what i would do the next time
you're in that moment you're afraid to
do something
right fear of rejection is creeping up
imagine yourself as a 95 year old you're
in an old age home you're sitting on
your rocking chair and and life is
almost over for you
and you think about the past x number of
years decades
between where you are now where you are
95 and this moment right now
was the thing that would change your
life for the better forever
and because you were too afraid you
spend your entire life regretting not
doing it
because you very rarely regret the
things that you do it's the things not
done that you regret
and so you've just spent the past x
number of decades
in regret hating your life because you
didn't do the thing
and at least for me that creates enough
pain that i have to do the thing
and so you create a stronger negative
emotion you don't overcome
emotions with logic in the moment when
you're very emotional
you overcome emotion with a stronger
emotion and the easier way to do it is
to go negative
and so the pain that you're about to
face is very real i just create a much
bigger pain so it forces me to action
just like if you have a hangnail it
hurts but if you punch yourself in the
arm or somebody hits you
you don't feel this anymore because this
hurts too much so create that pain of
regret
a future regret that if you don't do
this thing
you're gonna hit your life forever and
so now you're able to do that small
thing
that small scary thing and face possible
rejection
strategy number two is create a stronger
positive emotion so instead of going
negative you go positive now i love
going positive but i find the negative
actually works
better in these acute situations but net
i want to be positive so the positive
solution is
i want to be a hero you want to be a
hero you want to be strong you tell
yourself that you're strong for doing
these things
that you're a hero for doing these
things that you're getting stronger that
you're building muscle
that that you do scary things that
you're afraid of rejection
that that's not a good enough reason
that you do scary things
because you are a hero because you're on
a mission because you're going to change
the world because you're going to have a
huge impact
and that means you have to do it so it's
not trying to fight it logically because
logic won't work again
logic doesn't work against an emotional
situation
you need stronger emotion to combat the
emotion so just saying well they
probably won't reject me or
what's the worst that's gonna happen is
not as powerful as
i am a hero i do difficult things
i face rejection i risk things not
working out
i risk humiliation and i get through it
because
i am a hero so step one is go negative
step two is go positive and then step
three is
expect to suck and tie yourself forth to
the effort
one of the big problems people have is
you tie your self-worth
to the outcome that if you don't get a
yes then you suck as a human
you expect to be great and then when
you're not great you hate yourself
right and then you expect to win and
when you don't win you hate yourself
this is this is why people don't have
self-confidence self-respect
self-love because they tie their
self-worth to the result
where you want to do the opposite you're
going to go do this thing that you've
never done before
and you're going to suck at it like
everything else you've done that you've
never done before
doesn't mean you suck as a human you
just don't have the skills yet because
it's the very first time that you've
done it
and then you tie yourself worth what you
love about yourself where your
confidence
pulls from to the fact that you were
willing to try
not to that you won because tying your
self-worth
to winning means you only do things that
you're going to win at
means you play small for life where if
you tie yourself forth to i'm gonna try
things
that will risk failure that will risk
rejection
then your life will grow exponentially
because you're not worried about hitting
the outcome
you're worried about the growth you're
worried about you building you learning
you're growing
as a human and if every day you're off
doing things that you're part of your
effort for
i guarantee you your life will look
dramatically different
one year from today so try it one create
a stronger negative emotion two create a
stronger positive emotion and three
expect to suck and tie your self-worth
to the effort not the results
stop thinking that you should be
fearless
if you go through life fearless that
means you are playing small and not
doing anything that is worth doing you
should be dreaming big
you should be pushing boundaries and in
that push
comes fear instead of trying to be
fearless
adopt the mindset that you want to feel
the fear
and do it anyway otherwise you will
never take on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission
and you'll always live below the
potential that you know you're capable
of
if you are doing something new you are
going to get rejected
if you're doing something that you're
not good at yet you're going to get
rejected
if you're doing something that goes
against the status quo
you are going to get rejected so you
have two choices
live a life with zero growth and never
get rejected
or chase your dream deal with the
rejection that comes
and go change the world i have rejection
all the time in my life
from little rejections of making videos
that don't pop to bigger rejections of
projects that i care
deeply about that just don't fly and
people don't accept at the beginning
i look i look at this built to serve
this is a great example built to serve
is my new book this book i'm insanely
proud of
i think it's life-changing i mean it
should be i think the work that you
create
should be life-changing but i poured so
much into this and i think people need
to read it
like i i desperately think that this
book
will change a lot of people's lives it
could change your life i believe it's
not just hyperbole like
i i truly fundamentally believe it when
i came up with the idea
i was on my tour earlier this year and i
did not have time to write it
right i was on my tour i'm behind on
everything
a million things being thrown at me
meeting people doing my events seeing
the cities
and i just i just decided i have to
write this book because of all the
feedback i was getting from people
it was all the one-on-ones i was doing
with people the same questions kept
coming up how do i find my purpose how
do i know who i am how do i turn into a
business and so
that's the that's the point of the book
figuring out what your purpose is and
how to use that to then serve the world
right it's called built to serve
and make it into a business so you can
make money doing it and build a team and
go off and live your mission
when i first pitched my publisher on it
they didn't want it
they didn't want my book right so uh
your one word is down here
that's with penguin random house and
penguin passed so
they had first my first deal with uh
penguin random house
typically how they'll do deals
especially with first-time authors is
you get you get a deal and then they
have the right of first refusal in your
next book
so as soon as i get my next book they
get the right to look at it first before
i give it to anybody else right so
that's why i signed so okay here we go
let's go it's a perfect fit i mean it
follows really nicely with your one word
let's go right and they said uh no we're
gonna pass
like yeah what how do you this is better
than your one word i mean i love your
one word it's great
but this is this is this is the whole
thing
how do you pass on this um it's just
and we had to wait because it's 30 days
and all these anyway legal stuff
um so then we started looking at other
companies we started looking at other
publishing houses
and there were other ones that seemed to
line up really well with the content
that they had
the the author lineup that they had and
almost everybody everybody except the
last one right
uh said no and
i mean like i got a i got a big youtube
channel we have momentum we already have
our first book we're
like why and all sorts of different
reasons
you know um just not not doing personal
development books anymore
not whatever uh nobody came out and said
like we hate you evan so maybe
hopefully that's not the reason um and
then we found one that that
picked it up it's like okay let's go
and if if that one didn't pick it up
then then we would have kept looking for
more publishers or i would have just
made it myself
just self-publishing put it out right
what do you do when the people around
you don't accept what you have when you
want to take something in a new
direction i could have done something
else i could have done something easier
if i just did a book about jack ma right
in his real
success that would be easier to pick up
than this
which i talk about on the channel but
it's not the main thesis of the channel
but that's what i want to make and
that's what i'm going to make whether
it's i get a publisher or we're going to
you know create it myself it's going to
be birthed into existence because i
decided so
and just taking that mindset and
approach you have to if you love the
thing if you're doing something
different
then you have to keep going when people
say that i don't want to pick it up that
it sucks that it's stupid that
you're maybe it's even a great idea but
you're not the person who's gonna do it
right you have to keep going so i get
rejecting all the time
um most recently on the book that's a
big thing
and i'm proud that we got our publisher
at least and we're getting it out and
we're doing the tour and
that's it it's amazing even even the
tour i wanted to start in january for
the tour right january 16th we're gonna
be in cleveland
it's official the book's not coming out
until march
something 23rd 17th something like that
and like you want you to hold off on the
tour until the book's ready like no no
we're going
that was decided tour's happening we're
gonna start a tour and we'll do
pre-orders
until until the book is out and then we
can hand it out to people at the end and
mail it out to the people
who came before right like you decide
and you make stuff happen
and people will constantly have their
own agenda and own ideas for what you
should do with your life
you need to own what you want to do with
your life and then will it into
existence
so how do you do it i'm going to give
you a three-step process that i think
will help step number one is tie your
self-worth to the effort not the outcome
this is this
is this is one of the biggest things
that holds entrepreneurs back
you tie your self-worth to the result to
the outcome
you're great because a publisher says
yes right if that's why
if that's how i tied myself worth i'm
only good
if i get a million subscribers i'm only
good
if a publisher says yes no no i'm
awesome i wrote an amazing book this
book is fire
it's life-changing for people and evan
carmichael is awesome for writing it
whether a publisher loves it or not
right
because if you take that mindset right
take that substitute your name and your
project in that sentence you take that
mindset and you start to apply it
and you believe you're awesome for the
work that you're creating that allows
you
the strength the fortitude the
persistence to keep going
right it doesn't mean never listen to
feedback if a publisher said like
tweak it like this and tweak it like
that and maybe we could do a deal you
listen to it you're open you have to
match what you love with
what the demand is but if you felt
like you're insanely proud of your
effort for everything you create
you will go off and create amazing
things if you constantly tie your
self-worth to whether somebody likes it
or not
you're going to lose for life because
you're tying yourself forward to people
who have a lower standard than you
it doesn't make sense you're never going
to win you want to be creative
disruptive
a game-changing badass world-changing
entrepreneur like you have to
bet on yourself on your ideas when
people think you're crazy i look at the
thumbnails that i've done on my on my
youtube channel
i split test maybe more than anybody on
youtube we've done almost 1500 different
split tests on titles and thumbnails
and every time i go through it every
time i finish a round of another 10
different
variations new ideas right i'm always
trying to beat my best
i feel amazing like man i just made this
this is i love it i think this is going
to be the thing i always think it's
going to win
i don't make something that i think is
gonna lose i think it's gonna win
but most of the time it loses most of
the time it loses
and when it loses like ah crap
right now what just go back to what
we're doing that's not acceptable we got
to keep going keep building
but i feel great that i tried i'm still
proud of the effort even though
all of the things i created for those
sample thumbnails they're all in the
garbage i must have
[Music]
thousands thousands of thumbnails that
didn't even get to testing
that i'm still proud that i made that
just never saw
the light of day so being proud of your
effort
like what are you doing right now that
you're proud of your effort on whether
you win the race or not
you tried your hardest because if every
day you wake up and you try your hardest
you're going to win way more races than
you thought possible but if all you're
focused on is winning that one race
and you lose and then you quit and give
up you're losing on life
tie your self-worth to the effort not
the outcome
step number two is find another way
there's always another way right there's
always another way
this is the entrepreneur mindset it's
not about the resources it's about how
resourceful you are right there's
always another way what's the other way
for the book the other way is go find
another publisher go find another
publisher go find another publisher or
self-publish it myself or turn it into a
youtube video that
is three hours long and i read the whole
thing i don't know there's always
another way
there's always another way don't stop at
the first no or the second no or the
80th no
there is always another way
just adopt it if you love this thing
because here's here's what's gonna
happen if you love it
if you love it you know you have to
create this thing it's inside you you
love it
and you stop you're gonna regret it your
whole life you're gonna regret that you
didn't push a little bit harder a little
bit more
try another angle tap into your genius
but if you keep going even though you
haven't got a yes yet even though you
haven't got a win yet
but you love it you have to keep going
you have to keep going so you don't
regret the rest of your entire life
right there's always another way just
embody it
embrace it believe it the thing that you
want to do
is genius trust it keep going and find
another way and step number three is
what i call the tom bill you list
and this is not something i subscribe to
but works up for other people
like tom and so i wanted to share it for
you as an option tom's talked a lot
about
how he keeps a list so he's got a list
of people who doubted him
who told him he was never gonna make it
uh who told them that he was stupid or
an idiot or just
you know never gonna make it they didn't
believe in him insulted him either rude
or just said no to him and he wrote
their names down on the list and he's
got this list where there's actually a
like a
a printed list or just a list in his
head um and anytime he feels like he
doesn't want to get out of bed
anytime he's had a particularly bad day
then he reminds himself of the list
and he starts thinking about the people
and as if i don't get out of bed and go
do this thing
i'm that person is right and it fuels
him to get off and go off and do the
thing
right now you don't want to live in
negativity you
you don't want to only do the thing
because your uncle joe says you're an
idiot and you're never going to do it
right uncle joe not believing in you
can't be the motivation and
the sole reason for you going off but in
moments of acute
pain right you're you're 80 90 driven by
the positive and the inspiring
and the mission and the change that
you're trying to create and then the
final 10 and 20
when you need just that little extra
kick going to the dark side and saying
i'm going to prove uncle joe ron or
whoever
screwed you over and doesn't believe in
you i don't go there
that doesn't motivate me but it does for
highly successful entrepreneurs like tom
and other people so i wanted to give you
the option
try out the tom bill you list the next
time you are feeling low
energy and not following through and you
got rejected
use those names to propel you forward
and say
i am going to do it to prove you wrong
this is why it's so important that you
love what you do success is painful
it's a lot of work a lot of stress a lot
of failure
a lot of rejection but the thing that
gets you through it
is you love what you do you love the
process you love the work
you love the growth if you don't love
the work you do you will give up because
it will just become too painful to keep
going
so at the whole foods this morning when
i went to go get my bulletproof coffee
i ran into a friend of mine an
entrepreneur friend of mine who i told
about my tour
in december before i left and she was
super excited and i hadn't connected
with her since i got back
i went on this three month 90 day 23
city tour
across the u.s and it was amazing
happened since to meet her at the whole
foods
this morning and she said how's the tour
what was the best part of it
and i said break in my neck two-thirds
of the way through i broke my neck
i broke my neck in two spots i
compressed my spine i had a concussion
had to get staples in my head
all of it she said breaking your neck
that's the best part of your torah
that's a really positive outlook like
it's not just a positive outlook it's
the best
like it actually was the best part
because it really got the test like why
this sounds crazy but this is it this is
this is the process this is the mindset
shift
i want you guys to make that you do
difficult things
you love difficult things you don't want
it to be easy easy means you're inside
your comfort zone
easy means you're not pushing up against
any barriers you don't want to be easy
stop getting these easy small tiny wings
that you can snack on
you do difficult things you love taking
on amazing huge things that's who you
are
that's what you do and this was a chance
for me to grow
and help cement that for myself
rejection is part of life as an
entrepreneur
you are going to get rejected over and
over and over and over again it's just
part of being an entrepreneur and being
a business
the first thing you put out won't be
very good people will hate on it people
give some constructive criticism
as well people will say no because they
don't know you trust you like you
and so you won't get those first deals
it takes a lot of time to build up a
business and make it successful and even
when you've gotten to that point where
you're feeling happy and you're bringing
on a team and
building the business you're still going
to get rejected constantly it's just
part of life as an entrepreneur so if
you can't handle that
it's going to be a really hard road for
you to be an entrepreneur
i think the way to get through rejection
there's two ways to do it one is use
rejection as fuel
kind of like what jack ma did like i got
rejected 10 times by harvard one day i'm
gonna go teach
there right when they're gonna go speak
there to use that as she was like you
turned me down
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna beat it i'm
gonna
come back and be the teacher there right
you turn me down for this deal i'm gonna
go get a deal 10 times as big
right so that's one you can easily you
can use rejection as fuel to help you go
off and do something
bigger and motivation to i'm going to
prove them wrong
the second way is just to forget about
it just
get used to it that's more what i do i
don't really use rejection as fuel
doesn't really bother me when somebody
turns me down or when a new
series doesn't work i was trying to
think when i was preparing for this
video what's the recent rejection that i
have
because there's been so many but none
really stick out as being super
memorable
the one that i came up with was i tried
a new series on the weekend
a while ago about the best of
kickstarter and it was a new series that
i was testing of
showing different kickstarter ideas that
i thought might be helpful for you
and that video didn't do as well as i
would have liked didn't do as well as
other videos
and we're probably gonna kill that
series but that's okay like i've killed
tons of series
it happens all the time on the channel
and i couldn't even tell you all the
series
that i've killed because they didn't
perform you guys rejected them
it's okay i just moved past it and so
either one you have two strategies to go
for use the rejection
as fuel to say i'm gonna show you how
wrong you are
and prove it to them or just forget
about it
get used to it it's going to happen just
part of the game and you move on
and just think about the next thing you
can go off and build use either one of
those strategies but don't get stuck in
the rejection
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus
pdf calendar check the link right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there